just when you think you're saving the
planet a staggering 84 of us are doing
the opposite it's dry mixed recycling
cardboard paper tins glass simple type
of things we use every single day hidden
in this mountain of waste are items that
are so-called contaminated too soggy too
greasy or just downright wrong paper
cardboard plastic bottles it doesn't say
wood fishing them out adds extra cost or
sometimes writes off an entire batch of
recycling sometimes it can be an entire
load that comes in where eight or nine
tons is rejected immediately the smaller
bits we can't pick out smaller stuff as
coffee cups those uh you know
contaminated bits of cardboard Etc that
we can't really segregate if we see it
we pull it out our job in the main is
the larger quantities where there's food
waste nappies that type of thing and we
get quite a lot of it misplaced items
include crisp packets juice cartons soft
plastic bags wet cardboard and
toothpaste tubes which all require
specialist recycling
it's why households in England will get
updated guidance from the government to
clear up the mess that's largely been
caused by confusion rather than
ignorance definitely with that question
mark with that and no to that would it
surprise you that if the pizza box had
grease stains on it you wouldn't be able
to recycle it that does surprise me gosh
I didn't know if they had grease stains
in it we can't recycle that I would just
make it into an airplane well now when I
go home I'm gonna think should I or
shouldn't I misguided recyclers do need
a helping hand though with labeling
often causing a headache for both Depots
and households the responsibility lies
with with everyone so I think from a
government perspective there needs to be
make sure as clear legislation
guidelines to make sure that recycling
is as easy as possible so at the end of
the day the the final behavior is down
to to households and consumers to to
make sure that they are putting it into
the right bin
recycling was once a trend and is now a
norm with new guidance it's hope for
many more to become a habit Ashna
horanag Sky News